this program is brought to you by Emory
University
the Braveheart welcome back veterans
southeast initiative is a collaboration
between Emory University and the Atlanta
Braves sponsored by the Robert McCormick
Foundation and Major League Baseball
it's an outreach program to try to reach
veterans and families in the southeast
and educate them about post-traumatic
stress disorder readjustment issues help
them screen themselves and see if
they're having issues that require some
attention and if they are to help hook
them up with services in their area
we've got a spot on the website that you
can type in your zip code and find
services available near you
when someone is suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
very often they're feeling haunted by
what happened to them in their past they
may think about it when they don't want
to when they do think about it it
doesn't feel good it upsets them in
their bodies it upsets them emotionally
very often they try to avoid thinking
about it avoid any reminders or triggers
very often they are cut off from people
around them and not experiencing
emotions like they used to
they have problems sleeping problems
concentrating very often feel very
irritable or have angry outbursts are
easily startled and in some ways are
almost always waiting for the other shoe
to drop
even though they're back in the United
States and they know they're not in a
war zone they still feel very vulnerable
and like something could happen at any
minute to them or someone they love
we have worked with so many veterans
over the years that came back and have
even told us I don't know why I fought
so hard to survive if this is my life
now and we have seen them after therapy
say I feel like the person I was before
and I didn't think that was possible so
I can't guarantee it but I know it's
possible and a real believer in the
resiliency of the human spirit and
sometimes it just needs a little help to
bounce back
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University